regiert christina prostazyklin weg eine
schwierige sache sich auf die regentin
gegen den matten machismo dieser branche
durchzusetzen
noch viel schwieriger allerdings ist es
überhaupt dirigentin werden zu können
zumindest wenn man in afghanistan lebt
in gewissen teilen des landes dürfen
dort die mädchen nicht zur schule
geschweige denn vom infizieren und
erstaunliche war es dieses jahr beim wef
in davos ein afghanisches mädchen
orchester aufspielte
wir haben dieses feministische wunder
von carbon gesucht
es hat gar nicht in florstadt oder mit
der dirigentin eckball war die 18
jährige mit dem taktstock ist eine
kämpfernatur
sonst hätte sie sich niemals
durchgesetzt gegen ihre sippel und
nordosten afghanistans man im
einflussgebiet der partie
[Musik]
mehrere meiner onkel haben gesagt wenn
du an die musikschule gehst ihre gäste
und interviews gibst dann bringen wir
dich um das tun wir dies wirklich aber
sie gaben mir angst ein
ja ich lebe gefährlich die entspannte
atmosphäre auf dem campus täuscht ihr
mitten in kabul wo terror fast an der
tagesordnung ist der gründer und
direktor des instituts ahmad macht hofft
dass junge frauen wie energie in das
land in eine bessere zukunft führen
der dienst steht für die neue generation
in afghanistan
die trotz aller probleme und hatten für
ihre rechte kämpfen
der direktor ich selber schon
lebensgefährlich verletzt worden
bei einem anschlag kaum ein tag vergeht
und morddrohungen gegen ihn und seine
schützlinge über 200 studenten besuchen
das nationalinstitut für musik ein
drittel davon den frauen
viele der studentinnen leben in einem
sogenannten weißen haus das heißt nicht
so weil die eltern tot wählen sondern um
mit ihnen die kinder sind wie tod seiner
eltern abgekommen vom rechten weg alle
mädchen hier haben mit der tradition
gebrochen
doch die wollen afghanistan nicht
verlassen sondern mithelfen bei der
modernisierung internationale
anerkennung tut ihnen natürlich gut
immer wieder schauen sie sich diesen
mitschnitt ihrer konzerte an
vor drei jahren auf usa-tournee bestaunt
von einem prominenten publikum
in kabul jedoch wird mit ihm die angst
nie ganz los bis vor kurzem hat sie
selbst noch im weißen aufgebot
doch seit ein paar monaten liegt sie am
start land endlich wieder vereint mit
ihrer familie die sie jahrelang nicht
gesehen weil sie in ihrer heimat um ihr
leben fürchten musste nun sind wir nach
gezogen jeder acht geschwister ihre
mutter und der vater der als leibwächter
arbeitet und deshalb weiß in welcher
gefahr seine tochter steckt immer wenn
sie aus dem haus geht mache ich mir
sorgen
das leben hier ist so unsicher aber die
regierung schützt uns nicht dabei ist
sie doch die erste frau afghanistans die
dirigiert die erst für dirigentin
einsatzstellen schiff kann factoring
das ist auch sein verdienst als medien
vor acht jahren unbedingt eine schule
besuchen projekte die für sie nachgab
und ihn und sie auch die wehren als ihr
herz für die musik entdeckt
[Musik]
nach der aufnahmeprüfung informierte ich
meinen vater ist in ordnung sagt er es
ist dein leben mach was du gut findet
meine mutter hingegen sagte dass sie
sich nicht für mädchen
doch mittlerweile sei auch die stolz auf
ihre tochter
neben den druck hefter probenbeginn an
verschiedenen schlaginstrumenten
doch sie sieht sich nicht nur als
musiker sondern vor allem als
vorkämpferin wenn ich die studierenden
dirigiere kommen hier oft die tränen
aber ich kann wirklich dirigentin werden
wenn ich weiter hart daran arbeite
dieses orchester zeigt der ganzen welt
was in afghanischen frauen steckt wenn
man sie nur frei aufspielen lässt
[Musik]